[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily use
of force experts testify in day eight of
the derek chovin trial the time of the
restraint period mr floyd was not
resisting the defense tries to score
points with the lead investigator did it
appear that mr floyd said i ate too many
drugs yes it did plus the tiger woods
crash investigation report is out the
golfing legend speeding more than 40
miles per hour over the limit there is
zero breaking uh throughout that
recording of the data recorder and it's
99 percent acceleration on the pedal why
isn't he facing prosecution or atlas for
the trial of derek chovin and of course
our colleague terry austin here too well
the battle of the experts has begun with
prosecutors calling their first paid
expert on the use of force brian
buckmeyer why was this expert so
important
yeah brian ross it was important for a
number of reasons first the prosecution
wanted to put out that at least an
expert reviewed this case and found that
the use of force was excessive they then
dug deeper into why but for the defense
we heard a very powerful argument that
the dispatcher's information that they
gave to derek shovin would give him a
reason to have a heightened sense and
for the first time we heard the defense
argue that the words i ate too many
drugs came out of derek sorry george
floyd's mouth now sergeant jordy singer
steiger sorry serves as an aide to the
officer of the inspector general for the
los angeles police department he said
he's reviewed about 2500 use of force
incidents in his career steiger said
he's reviewed reports and body cam video
from the case he then rendered his
opinion on chauvin's use of force
my opinion was that the force was
excessive
and were you able to
make any kind of assessment in this case
as to whether or not mr floyd was
offering resistance or trying to evade
law enforcement officers yes
and what was your assessment
initially
when
mr floyd was being placed in the
backseat of the vehicle
he was actively resisting the officers
so at that point officers were justified
in utilizing force to try to have him
comply with their commands and to seat
him in the back seat of the vehicle
however once he was uh placed in the
prone position on the ground he uh
uh
slowly sleeps his resistance and at that
point uh the officers uh
uh ex-officers i should say uh
they should have
slowed down or stopped their their force
as well
on cross-examination the defense was
quick to point out that striker has
never testified before as an expert in a
state or a federal court and has only
been qualified as an expert once in a
los angeles superior court eric nelson
then played a piece of body cam video
for steiger one he found to be
especially telling
i'd like you to see if you can tell me
what mr floyd says in this instance
[Music]
does it sound like he says i ate too
many drugs listen again
[Music]
i can't make that out now
so in the chaos of a situation things
can be missed right
yes
defense attorney nelson went on to ask
tiger about how the behavior of the
growing crowd could have an impact on
the officer's actions
but in terms of now you are an officer
and you're engaged with the suspect
right
and somebody else is now pacing around
and watching you and watching you and
calling you names and saying you're
this could be viewed by a reasonable
officer as a threat as a potential
direct correct
and in fact when that happens if you
look at the slide in front of you
once when how a person is talking to an
officer if they're mimicking them or
ragefill rachel
officers are specifically trained to try
to predict future behavior based on that
correct yes to prepare themselves right
and when someone starts threatening you
it's a possible possibility that an
officer can view that as a potential
deadly assault is about to happen
that's what they're trained yes
that's what they're trained
the defense then played even more videos
and photos from police body cams trying
to suggest chauvin's knee wasn't
actually on floyd's neck but instead on
his shoulder blades
here you've got the shoulder blade
shoulder blade mr chauvin's knee
is sort of at the base of the neck right
correct i would agree on the left-hand
side of your screen you see that appears
to be the bystander video yes on the
right-hand side that's from mr king's uh
body-worn camera yes you'd agree that at
this point based on everything that
we've seen in the same photographs on
the left hand side it appears that mr
shoven's knee is on mr floyd's neck
yes
more of the base of the neck
officer king's uh body worn camera it
appears that it was more at the base of
the neck in between the shoulder blades
right yes
and in fact um as you review some of the
videos while mr floyd was
uh on
uh on in the prone position
there are points in time at which mr
floyd picks up his head and moves it
agreed
he attempted to early on yes
he was stating he couldn't breathe so i
i assumed he was
attempting to try to breathe better
but he was able to
lift up his head at some points
turn it slightly yes he attempted to
so terry austin we heard sergeant
steiger testify about the placement of
chauvin's knees on floyd's body do you
think his testimony was more helpful for
the prosecution or for the defense
brian i think it's more helpful for the
prosecution clearly nelson made a little
point there when he said the left knee
was at the base of the neck but i think
steiger made it very clear okay the left
knee was on the neck or the base of the
neck and the right knee was definitely
on floyd's back so he clarified that
issue for the jury he also confirmed
that chovin's body didn't move that
position stayed the entire time of the
restraint and he most importantly brian
he gave his opinion that no force should
have been used once floyd was handcuffed
and put in the prone position so overall
i think he was a much better witness for
the prosecution and brian buckmeyer did
the defense in this battle of the
experts make any important points today
i think they did but what we're seeing
from the prosecution is that they're
adjusting to any arguments that eric
nelson is making specifically as terry
was mentioning eric nelson made a lot of
headway about the knee being on the back
rather than the neck so the prosecution
is now arguing that any weight on top of
george floyd regardless of neck or back
could kill him and also the defense is
zooming in only on the time of 8 28 when
the medical support is already there and
his knee has shifted i think the
prosecution keeps coming back to refute
any arguments that nelson may make as
good as they are all right well still
ahead on law and crime daily why derek
showman's attorneys are trying to make a
statement
[Music]
and welcome back a big development in
the crash involving tiger woods the los
angeles county sheriff's office now says
the golfer was speeding about 40 miles
an hour above the limit
the primary causal factor for this
traffic collision was driving at a speed
unsafe for the road conditions and the
inability to negotiate the curve of the
roadway estimated speeds at the first
area of impact were 84 to 87 miles per
hour and the final estimated speed
when the vehicle struck the tree was 75
miles per hour there were no citations
issued and there are no signs of
impairment i know there are some saying
somehow he received a special or a
preferential treatment any any of some
kind that is absolutely false
there was no signs of impairment our
primary concern once we
obviously at the scene of the collision
was uh his his safety
and this is where you you have to switch
gears and make sure
the person can survive and receives the
medical care they need and the
fire department paramedics and that's
why he was taken to a trauma center
because he obviously had compound
fracture to a leg and it was
life-threatening injuries
but no ticket no citation the lead
investigator says a field sobriety test
was not conducted and blood was not
drawn from tiger woods
the impact of the vehicle when they hit
the tree caused the vehicle to go
airborne and do a somewhat pirouette
landing on its side
the follow-up investigation after the
fact
as the sheriff indicated there was no
evidence of any impairment
there was no odor of alcohol
there were no open containers in the
vehicle
and there were no narcotics or any
evidence of medication
in the vehicle or on his person
in this situation the question was asked
about did we conduct field sobriety
tests due to his injuries in the
traumatic uh nature of his injuries it
would not be appropriate to do any type
of field sobriety test we did not seek a
warrant because there was no indication
for us to do so and and so based on all
the facts there was no evidence of any
impairment or intoxication and so in
order to obtain a search warrant you
have to have probable cause you'll be
able to articulate that and that did not
exist
but brian buckmeyer isn't it unusual in
a case like this that they wouldn't at
least draw his blood to see if there was
any evidence of alcohol or drugs
uh yes and no the main problem with that
question is this isn't a case or at
least the officers didn't believe it was
a case to begin with and so as the
officer was explaining without that
probable cause to go because you've got
to go to a judge and say hey this is why
we need a search warrant either to draw
his blood or to take the blood results
from the hospital no judge would
authorize that ability for them to
search his blood or his medical
paperwork so it'd be very hard for them
to do that unless there's some sort of
indication that he was intoxicated and
terry austin they deny there's any
special treatment but it looks like a
case of a celebrity catching a break
doesn't it
it sure does look like that to me they
said that there was no special treatment
here and they're saying that there was
no evidence of an impairment and that's
why they didn't do the field sobriety
test and they didn't do it also because
of his injuries and i understand that
brian if you're injured you're not going
to have the victim do a field sobriety
test but what about the citation for the
speeding ticket there's no question that
he was way over the speed limit so
certainly he should be getting a
citation for that so he caught a little
bit of a break there it does seem that
way all right well coming up on law and
crime daily back to the
back now to minnesota where a number of
police officers have been lining up to
testify against eric sheldon long crimes
kim johnson is in minneapolis for us and
has more on one of those officers who
might be doing just the opposite kim
yeah brian one of the witnesses the
state called in to help prove their case
caught the attention of the defense who
believes she may actually help theirs
minneapolis police officer nicole
mckenzie trains officers in medical
support prosecutors used her testimony
to show how police officers are trained
to provide medical attention like cpr
when needed on cross-examination defense
attorney eric nelson asked her about
egonal breathing which is described as
gas of breaths and can occur in people
who are in medical distress prosecutors
argue george floyd showed signs of this
but under defense questioning mckenzie
says it's not always so easy to
determine
a person observing someone going through
agonal breathing
it's common or it would be
possible that they would misinterpret
that as actual breathing effective
breathing yes that can be easily
confused with real breathing so that's
why we teach this is not effective
right
so an officer is
dealing with someone who's experiencing
agonal breathing it would potentially be
possible for an officer to misinterpret
agonal breathing for effective breathing
okay
and in certain circumstances where
there's a lot of noise or a lot of
commotion
would it be more likely that that could
happen yes
so there you have the defense using the
state's witness to show how other
factors could prevent officers from
rendering aid which one of the things at
the heart of this case what kind of
medical aid are minneapolis officers
trained to provide suspects in their
custody and also what is the cause of
floyd's death now the defense has argued
that george floyd died from drug use and
underlying heart issues not because of
anything derek shovin did mackenzie will
return to the stand next tuesday when it
is the defense portion of the trial
brian and kim do you think there'll be
any other police witnesses who testify
on behalf of derek shelvin
well you would it's hard to believe that
they wouldn't right it would be very
powerful to have an actual working
minneapolis police officer or any police
officer come in and say derek shovin was
not in the wrong for doing what he did
and in fact that is proper use of force
and what minneapolis police officers are
trained to do right now the witness
lists are not made public so we don't
know exactly if that will be the case
and who will come in but we will
certainly find out
who the defense calls to testify
all right kim johnson thank you so much
from a very busy hennepin county
courthouse up next the lead investigator
into the death of george floyd takes the
stand his surprise admission during
cross-examination that'll be next
now with more on the derrick sheldon
case with a surprising admission on the
stand from the lead investigator during
cross-examination our angenette levy is
here to explain what happened anjanet
brian james ryerson is the lead
investigator into the investigation into
george floyd's death he works for
minnesota's bureau of criminal
apprehension and he actually used to
work for the drug enforcement agency
also known as the dea he testified about
that second search of squad 320. that's
the cruiser that officers were trying to
get george floy into last floyd into
last may that second search happened
months after floyd died at the request
of derek chovin's attorney after he saw
something white in the back seat in some
crime scene photos agents went back and
found fentanyl pills with george floyd's
dna on them then there was a big moment
on cross-examination when chauvin's
lawyer asked him about how thoroughly he
had reviewed the body camera videos in
the case
i've seen all of them i've reviewed some
most of them
closely yes okay and did you attempt to
understand and hear
what various parties were saying at
various times
yes
do you did you ever hear mr floyd say
i ate too many drugs
no
[Music]
did you hear that yes i did did it
appear that mr floyd said i ate too many
drugs yes it did
now after ryerson made that statement it
was kind of surprising i think to both
sides there was a break taken by the
court ryerson came back after the break
and told the prosecutors that he
actually heard floyd say
i ain't do any drugs so that's a big
difference brian antoinette that's a key
moment there that we're going to hear a
lot about i'm sure as we go forward
what do you make make of this change by
the testimony of the lead agent
you know i thought it was pretty
interesting and it seems
uh odd to me that he hadn't heard that
before being the least lead case agent
and saying he had reviewed those body
camera videos also he took a break
the court took a break it seemed like a
bombshell moment they come back from the
break and he says that he hears
something that plays differently so
you're going to have to wonder it leads
me to wonder how the jury is going to
interpret all of that and brian buckman
let me ask you is this a case of poor
preparation by the prosecution of an
important witness
i think it is and i also think the
prosecution
witness kind of jumped the gun a little
like you saw in an earlier witness they
kind of listened and and said they
didn't hear it but when the prosecution
came back and put the larger context of
that video in and and you heard that
statement in coordination with the other
statements it started to make a little
bit more sense and i think the worry for
the defense here is did he lose a little
bit of credibility on what was a very
strong argument absolutely and terry the
special agent wiseman said that he went
through all of the critical incident
protocol so far it sounds like his
investigation was fairly thorough what
are your thoughts on this so far
well i think brian it was extremely
thorough i think he went through all the
body cam he went through all the
bystander videos he went through the
milestone videos he looked through
multiple documents they said there were
50 bca agents who were working with him
and they were paired up with 25
different fbi agents so it is possible
that he could have missed some small
things like what was said when floyd was
there whether or not he said i ate too
many drugs or i ain't doing no drugs
either way it's possible that he could
have missed it and one thing i'll say
about the preparation for this witness
we know steiger like brian buckmeyer
said
listened to the video and hesitated and
basically said um i did not hear him say
i ate too many drugs and maybe that is
something that ryerson should have said
as well but i do think it was a good
move on the prosecution's part to come
back up and clarify that point and they
did do that and that was the last word
that the jury heard and to angenette's
point it's going to be up to what the
jury heard so they'll probably call that
back when they are deliberating and
listen to that once again no doubt brian
buckmeyer certainly the power of
suggestion is important too right the
first thing they heard was i ate too
many drugs
absolutely you want to plant that seed
in a juror's mind and try to have it
replayed over and over again of course
if you keep saying either sentence you
start to hear it more and more yourself
so either side wants to push that
narrative as best as possible right now
i think the prosecution has a little bit
of a leg up on the defense when it comes
to the question of i ate or i ain't do
to do too many drugs and terry austin
the whole point for the defense here is
to suggest that uh george floyd died
because he ate those drugs it was a drug
overdose
that's right that's why that position is
very important to make sure that the
jury hears that sentence the fact that
george floyd said he had too many drugs
not just i have some drugs but i ate too
many drugs so that's a critical point
for nelson to try to establish there and
if he can get the jury to hear that that
i do think that they will be thinking to
themselves wow i ate too many drugs from
my own system and maybe that is in fact
the reason that he you know quote
unquote od as far as the defense is
concerned and that's probably a tape
that i want to replay and listen to in
debate inside the jury room once
deliberations begin all right well thank
you all for joining us here on long
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we continue to discuss
justice in america